close to 50,000 Americans died from
opioids last year that's about one death
every 10 minutes I almost never hear
anyone in power talk about what's
happening but it's changing this country
forever communities are collapsing
entire zip codes are being depopulated
opioids have fueled the single deadliest
public health crisis in our lifetimes by
far how did this start was started with
men in lab coats Purdue Pharma the maker
of oxycontin
when oxycontin was introduced Purdue
plane without any evidence at all the
users of it run likely to become
addicted to the product that was a lie a
lie that caused an epidemic oxycontin
and other painkillers turned out to be
terrifyingly addictive many hundreds of
thousands of Americans have entered into
a death spiral of addiction after being
prescribed these drugs by doctors the
disaster began more than 20 years ago
and yet only now is Purdue Pharma
collapsing under the weight of a wave of
lawsuits how did the company get away
with this for so long well the answer
tells you so much about how the
propaganda machine works in modern
America having made billions destroying
an entire generation Purdue Pharma used
some of those profits to pay for good
publicity and boy did they get it some
of the PR budget went to nonprofits in
Washington according to reporting by
ProPublica from 2003 until very recently
Purdue Pharma gave $50,000 a year to the
American Enterprise Institute
AEI is a conservative think tank in
Washington one of the richest the money
turned out to be very well spent for
about the price of a car for new Pharma
bought years of positive coverage from
AEI that helped the company escape
scrutiny for the many deaths it was
causing at the same time in 2004 for
example an AEI scholars to piece in The
New York Times lamenting the plight of
doctors who risk jail time for over
prescribing painkillers the article
cited two studies showing that oxycontin
abuse was almost non-existent among
those who had been prescribed the drug
well as it turns out the study was
conducted and paid for by Purdue Pharma
researchers yet the article didn't
mention that fact that key fact it also
didn't mention the fact that the piece
had been coordinated directly with the
drug company
email show that AEI is scholar the one
who wrote the piece sent a draft of the
article to Purdue Pharma chief lobbyist
a month before the article came out
seeking his approval of the text and
making certain it didn't seem to
blatantly pro Purdue pretty stealthy in
2007 that same AEI scholar an article
for The Wall Street Journal entitled
oxymoron the piece briefly chastised
Purdue for over promoting its drugs but
then and this was the real point of it
it described oxycontin as quote a
godsend and worried that physicians
might not prescribe the drug in
sufficient quantities the problem with
oxycontin in other words is that America
doesn't have enough of it as for there
many people were starting to drop dead
from oxycontin the article dismissed
them as quote committed substance
abusers the year that article appeared
18,000 people died of opioid overdoses
that was more than double the number for
just a few years before the epidemic was
starting to rage out of control and yet
according to AEI z' expert scholar quote
the real public health damage here comes
from the pitched campaign by zealous
prosecutors and public interest
advocates to demonize the drug itself
end quote again according to AEI the
real crisis was the fact that not enough
Americans were taking oxycontin this was
in effect ad copy no different from a
glossy insert tearing the life enhancing
benefits of some new consumer product
except in one way one key way it was
very different readers had no idea it
was an ad for oxycontin they assumed it
was what it claimed to be scientific
research by well-respected free-market
think-tank AEI there was no mention of
funding from Purdue Pharma hey I kept
that information to itself meanwhile
thousands kept dying many ironically in
this country's reddest states so a
conservative think-tank ran interference
for a company whose products were
disproportionately killing conservatives
yeah just another day in Washington if
you're starting to suspect that the
conservative establishment doesn't
really represent your interests there's
a reason for that they're every bit as
corrupt as you think they are